I'm Joanna and I believe that creating a
functional Android app and a great
Android app are two different things
but only one of them will help you
engage and delight users and that's why
you'd ask be partnered with Google to
produce advanced Android app development
which explains how to make an app stand
out with a kind of polish that leads to
success in the Google Play Store
students will learn how to improve the
appeal and speed of their apps UI with
material design features and helpful
libraries as well as how to widen their
audience and reach all sorts of users
with simple localization and
accessibility updates they'll also learn
how to expand their apps functionality
by building an app widget and
integrating with Google Cloud messaging
for efficient server and network use so
check it out it's gonna be awesome